bientôt s'excuse il est écouté
aujourd'hui comme vous pouvez le baril a
pas laissé derrière moi ya juste deux
mots qui me regardent avec une tête
terrifié sabah jumbo parce que je suis
en plein déménagement ces jours ci c'est
un gros bordel bref écouter aujourd'hui
on se retrouve pour une vidéo un peu en
mode b spec parce que c'est un bordel de
malades dans tout l'appartement donc je
peux pas aller filmer des scènes
d'ailleurs que je faisais luke walton
taille mais j'avais quand même envie de
faire une vidéo j'interagis avec vous
donc j'ai demandé sur twitter de me
poser des questions de me dire des trucs
voilà et puis je vous répondais de
manière totalement naturelle
c'est parti pour la vidéo bas les steaks
à ne pas confondre avec balais stakes à
ce canton qui a volé un steak et que
l'on retrouve par terre dans la cuisine
as tu déjà été hospitalisé oui une fois
j'ai eu à peu près 18 points de suture
sur la main parce que j'ai défoncé un
mec dans un bar du coup il me regarde et
moi je suis comme un sa toile au bond la
vérité est extrêmement humiliante
en fait on avait des horaires avec mon
frère moi je faisais du pc 18 à 19
heures et lui s'étaient 19 heures à 20
heures et il est arrivé à 19 heures
j'étais en plein combat sur dofus
comprenez vous à la 16 heures du grand
dossier attention et du coup à 19h05 il
a craqué il a éteint le pc de force et
il m'a dégagé du bureau et pour exprimer
mon mécontentement en tant qu homme
viril et ben j'ai tapé dans un kart
voilà du coup depuis je frappe dans des
oreillers extrêmement mou à chaque fois
je m'énerve comme ça ça nique encore
plus ma crédibilité c'est super as tu eu
hâte de déménager
nous en tant qu homme sérieux ouais ça
me fait plaisir mais je suis pas plus en
plus de pièces un bureau plus grands un
bureau plus grands un bureau clou c'est
pour quand la muscu alors attention
deuxième gros dossier aujourd'hui si la
vidéo des dossiers c'est génial je me
suis inscrit à la salle de musculation
1 pourquoi les gaules et vous et c'est
sous forme d'abonnement donc tu peux
tous les mois pour pouvoir y aller et
j'y suis allée seule fois en trois mois
mais saab ou c'est un peu un tel une
plante j'ai trouvé l'angle mais il n'y
en a pas c'est toujours petit en fait
entre jo et mon chat tu penses que
lequel est le plus gros aaa
je pense qu'il ya pas photo ça va du
monde attend ça vaille en direct et des
paralysés mon grand ami et l'inde état
de choc qui était plus penser à plus
tard sa chose qui volent c'était [ __ ]
de poils bordel essaie de rentrer en
entier dans une valise pour voir à quel
point tu un corps de lâche moi à à sa
sainteté est ok c'est un test officiel
quoi pour savoir si tu as un corps de
l'âge tu regardes tu peux en train d'une
valise si tu peux rentrer et un corps de
la jma ok ok le vendeur m'a dit si tu ne
peux pas rentrer là dedans ça veut dire
que tu es l'homme le plus viril de
france je peux mettre que ma jambe
fais toi une coupe totalement
dégueulasse avec du gel alors c'est
impraticable voilà c'est un terrain
c'est du hors piste quoi la seule
technique que j'ai c'est la dicaprio
technique voilà je mets mon casque de
cette manière là et c'est moche mais
moins enfin je crois
fait théorie hyper compliqué sur la rage
dans les jeux vidéo écoute extrêmement
simple voilà quand tu joues un jeu et
que tu n'arrives pas à faire le même
passage entre 20 et 400 [ __ ] de foi et
ben tu te lèves tu prends du papier
protégeant ok tu t'en roule du nord où
la houle excelor une pâte et bien roulé
tu prends un carton comme ça tu comptes
jusqu'à 3 600 tonnes du temps mm ce que
tu a déchiré du papier km des positions
de boeuf et en plus tu te débrouilles
est vrai que le carton c'est cool je
vais faire la fragile
merci de nous faire rire avec tes vidéos
merci d'être toi et de nous partager
tu mets au top côté de toi qu'est ce que
c'est que ce bordel de doux maintenant
dire à quelqu'un que tu aimes bien ce
qu'il fait c'est chouette un fragile
soit être un futur qui a marqué qu'à
plus en plus de gens qui aiment bien
quelqu'un mais qui ne lui disent pas
parce que c'est la honte voilà parce que
les copains m'ont fait rare aux soeurs
et faites ce que vous voulez aborder si
vous aimez un truc vous le dites si vous
connaissez vous l'aimez pas vous le
dites aussi on veut on s'en fout c'est
l'opinion personnelle
par exemple moi je m'aime pas je le dis
que ce taux baisse du cac lg des biceps
à nantes elle à lhassa cinq fois et
attend comment tu sais ça - de squeeze
et plus de gamme bon ça c'est une
tentative de mutinerie c'est ça vient à
la main qu'on secoue y que je tends
balles de papier il n'y a pas une robe
de mariée un petit peu savez je crois
que j'ai découvert le secret des
couturiers juste du papier protecteur en
fait mon sac auquel tirmarche solar
offre un plat ya plus de robes les
[ __ ]
donne nous ton secret pour faire des
périlleux arrière alors c'était simple a
donc tu te mets comme ça sur ton siège
tu vas en arrière et c'est très
périlleuse que tu vois pas ce qu'il ya
derrière donc hâte en train de faire un
périlleux arrière voilà à bercy
c'est quelque chose
quel est pour toi la pire et la
meilleure des vidéos que tu es fait j'en
ai aucune idée mais celle des vacances
une vidéo je suis plus content que
d'autres et pourtant ça veut pas dire
que la vidéo va vieux mas revient à
mieux me va bien gras va mieux marché
que d'autres pardon donc je n'en sais
rien finalement ça dépend de l'opinion
personnelle de chacun pourquoi ne change
pas de coiffure ben j'ai tenté de
changer de coiffure avec et la fameuse
technique dicaprio voilà tout le monde
s'est foutu de ma gueule dans les
commentaires donc j'ai fini comme ça en
position foetale sous mon bureau que tu
rencontres tu es fan et que tu vois
qu'ils sont plus grands que toi alors
qu'ils ont 14 ans ça te fait quoi pas
moi j'ai 19 ans effectivement je fais
que un mètre soixante dix mohamed 69
j'aime bien dire 77 et puéril tagen die
par contre j'ai une théorie je trouve
que les gens qui sont nés entre 1999 et
maintenant leur morphologie est abusé
les mecs qui ont 15 ans maintenant
c'était les mecs qui avaient 20 ans
avant les filles pareil c'est un
scandale total
entendez-vous cave et réseaux et qui
fait un mètre quatre-vingt-dix la bande
de mutants zdx même quel animal de
compagnie avait tu quand tu étais petit
eh ben mon frère avait acheté un hamster
est en fait quand il avait acheté le
vendeur devant lui a dit lequel tu veux
mon frère a dit lui et quand le mec a
mis ses doigts dans l'immense kg tous
les mystères pour le prendre
il a ressorti le hamster le hamster
pendait de ces deux doigts parce qu'il
avait mordu comme ça le mec puisse elle
sort tranquillement et il dit les fait
un très bon choix
à quel moment il a fait un bon choix il
appelait le seul absent du truc qui est
attendue du cannibalisme
je voulais te dire c'est que tu es un
début de calvitie alors non nommés des
formes le dit effectivement là et là
c'est vraiment où l'implantation des
cheveux qui a défaite complète depuis
tout petit remet les photos que je suis
petit j'ai ça c'est bizarre enfin je
veux dire c'est bizarre que je me
réconforte derrière cette excuse [ __ ]
sale au total 14 ans qui fait 18 et à
plein de cheveux csat étrangers ni comme
tous les autres un suce mon but n'est
pas tant les beats by dr dre on les
portait autour du cou folle et sucé
carrément césar c'est pas mal celle là a
été drôle t'as aucun style à mortal
kombat mois jo cascades mortal kombat 9
h et se déchirent match 6e
oui ça c'est technique que j'ai
développé pour impressionner une fille
pour faire genre que vous avez beaucoup
de force
vous achetez une chemise avec des
boutons qui juste crips comme ceux ci
est ce que tu participeras où tu as
participé à des conférences alors à des
conférences sur l'orthographe jamais été
pas mal à et blaya par n'ont jamais mais
par contre je compte peut-être en faire
bientôt j'ai vu qu'ils avaient la peau
les mangas et qui avait aussi la la peau
les mangas ou prévient la plage je me
souviens pas mais va être vu que je fais
quatre vidéos par semaine j'ai pas
forcément le temps de me déplacer pour
deux trois quatre jours parce qu'avant
de partir ses deux trois quatre jours il
faut que tu fasses deux fois plus de
vidéos avant sur l'avion même laps de
temps que si tu partais pas et du coup
des fois t'es un peu y avait quoi et
c'est tout sauf ce que je veux [ __ ]
c'est une sale tête jacky va fouiller
dans les cartons
il vient m'interrompt non mais regardez
bien les matadors il veut partir il
venait me voler ma place tomblaine vidéo
sans déconner le cheikh qui n'a aucun
respect pardon si tu veux un bon ben
voila j'ai attendu ma fille que je me
suis pas une chose bien trop quoi penser
- le parc du cdja fin de cette vidéo
j'espère que ça vous a plu et si ces cas
n'hésitez pas à lui mais comme
d'habitude bla bla bla bla bon du coup
j'étais un peu une vidéo bla bla bla les
bons titres comme ça vous aura fait un
peu mari puis voit cela fait plaisir
voilà façon je voulais la faire donc
j'ai fait devrait avoir complètement
fini le déménagement d'ici mardi
prochain mais vous en faites pas
dimanche soir y aura comme une vidéo qui
sortira mais bon voilà mardi concernant
une nouvelle pièce avec un un décor un
truc comme la ce qu'on a fait j'ai
beaucoup à tous du coup vient le moment
des adieux des radios du sud
donc je suis super alexandre 131,14
prochaine vidéo vers savoir regarder et
pétillant tout le monde au pis